hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I O
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught Philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on One Core concept from
an important philosophical text I hope
you find it useful as well
one of the key themes that runs
throughout Blaze pascals passes is a
sort of double-sidedness of human nature
that he thinks that we need to recognize
and keep in mind and constantly juggle
and deal with and that is a contrast
between on the one side the greatness
the Grandeur of human nature of human
beings and on the other side the
wretchedness or misery depending on how
you translate it Museum in French of
human beings as well and we're
positioned sort of in between these not
in a neutral zone but partaking of both
as we're going to see and the first
discussion of this in the brunch fig
Edition or arrangement of the passes
remember that there are multiple
Arrangements happens in the course of a
discussion of the two Infinities and of
thinking about ourself in relation to
the universe so you know he talks about
enlarging our conceptions beyond all
imaginable space retreating or returning
into oneself let let the human being
consider what they are in comparison
with all existence let them regard
himself as lost in this remote corner of
Nature and from the little cell in which
he finds himself lodged I mean the
universe let him estimate at their true
value these human things of the Earth's
kingdoms cities and himself what is a
man in the infinite and then we can look
at things being infinitely small as well
but the the main thing here is that he
tells us that we want to consider
ourselves in relation to what he calls
the two abysses or twin abysses of the
infinite and nothing right a person who
looks at themselves in this metaphysical
framework will be afraid of themselves
and observing themselves sustaining the
body given by Nature between these two
abysses will tremble at the sight of
these Marvels and I think as his
curiosity changes in admiration he will
be more disposed to contemplate them in
silence than to examine them with
presumption with pridefulness and then
he says here's the the real upshot
in fact what is the human being in
nature a nothing an eons in comparison
with the infinite and all unto in
comparison with the nothing a mean
between nothing and everything
since the human being is infinitely
removed from comprehending the extremes
the end of things in their beginning are
hopelessly hidden from him in an
impenetrable secret he's equally
incapable of seeing the nothing from
which he was made and the infinite in
which he is swallowed up so
metaphysically you know as for Descartes
uh arrival to Pascal the human being is
between being and nothingness now he
goes on from that to his famous dictum
of the human being as a thinking read
Rosso passant in uh much later section
and he tells us man is but a reed the
most feeble thing in nature
but he has a thinking read the entire
universe need not arm himself to crush
him right he could snap like a reed
uh a vapor a drop of water suffices to
kill him but if the universe were to
crush him
man would still be more noble than that
which killed him because he knows that
he dies and the advantage of the
universe has over him the universe knows
nothing of that so on the one side the
greatness of us consists in that
thinking on the other side
that doesn't guarantee anything for us
we can be snapped like a twig right and
so he says all our dignity consists then
in thought by it we must Elevate
ourselves not by time and space which we
cannot fill let us Endeavor then to
think well this is the principle of
Morality In the next section 348 he says
a thinking read it is not from space
they must seek my dignity but from the
government of my thought I shall have no
more if I possess Worlds by space the
universe encompasses and swallows me up
like an atom by thought I comprehend the
world so again we have this dialectic
between misery and and you know being
almost nothing in comparison with the
universe and the greatness that thought
allows us so another vital dimension of
this
uh he also talks about how we can view
human nature in multiple ways and or
through multiple Frameworks we might say
he tells us the nature of the human
being may be viewed uh in two ways the
one according to its its end its purpose
what it is that human nature was made
for and then it is great and
incomparable
the other according to the multitude
Just As we judge of the nature of the
horse and the dog popularly by seeing
its fleetness and then the human being
is abject and vile so again greatness
and misery these are the two ways which
make us judge of him differently and
which occasion disputes among
philosophers and here we're getting to
something very interesting right that
we're going to pick up very shortly he
says these are the two ways which make
us judge of differently in which
occasion disputes among philosophers one
denies the Assumption of the other one
says he is not born for this end for all
his actions are repugnant to it and the
other says he forsakes his end when he
does these base actions and he goes on
to talk about Port Royal which Pascal is
associated with in this section 416 for
Port Royal greatness and wretchedness
wretchedness being deduced from
greatness so now it's not just that
these are two different polls and two
different ways of looking at it our very
misery our very wretchedness is derived
from the greatness that we don't realize
this end of being a genuine human being
fitting into the the cosmos as a
creature of of God that has the capacity
to take in the cosmos and then failing
at that right and he says we also deduce
greatness from wretchedness
so some have inferred human wretchedness
all the more because they've taken their
greatness as a proof of it and others
have inferred greatness with all the
more Force because they've inferred it
from his very wretchedness all that the
one party has been able to say and proof
of his greatness has only served as an
argument of his wretchedness to the
others isn't that interesting so when
you make a proof for yourself
others who don't accept all the
assumptions that you have going on the
inferences they can interpret that in a
quite different way and he says because
the greater our fall the more wretched
we are and vice versa the one party is
brought back to the other in an endless
Circle it being certain that in
proportion as men possess light they
discover both the greatness and the
wretchedness of human beings in a word
the human being knows they are wretched
they are therefore wretched because they
are so
but they are really great because they
know it
he goes on and says the twofold nature
of man is so evident that some have
thought we had two Souls
a soul that's great and a soul that's
miserable a single subject seemed to
them incapable of such sudden variations
from unmeasured presumption to a
dreadful dejection of heart
and he says following up a little bit it
is dangerous to make human beings see
too clearly their equality with the
brutes the other animals without showing
them this greatness it's also dangerous
to make him see his greatness too
clearly apart from his vileness it is
still more dangerous to leave him in
ignorance of both so we have three
mistaken ways of going emphasizing
greatness
not focusing at all on misery
emphasizing misery not focusing on
greatness not teaching the human being
about either which is you know what they
are right at a very important uh level
and it goes on it's very advantageous to
show him both the human being must not
think he's on a level either with the
brutes or with the angels nor must he be
ignorant of both sides of his nature but
he must know both right
he goes on a little bit further after
this and says I blame equally those who
choose to praise the human being and
those who choose to blame or criticize
him and those who choose to amuse
themselves and I can only approve of
those who seek with lamentation all
right
now we're going to come back to the
philosophers
um he's going to tell us that the
philosophers have actually you know kind
of screwed things up in their own ways
he tells us this is an in section 524
the philosophers did not prescribe
feelings uh suitable to the two states
or appropriate feelings
proportione to these states of misery
and Grandeur so he tells us how
they inspired feelings of pure greatness
right and that is not man's state
pure greatness is great we we do
participate in greatness but not purely
they inspired feelings of pure
littleness that is also not The Human
Condition as well and he goes on and
says there must be feelings of humility
not from nature but from penitence not
to rest in them but to go on to
Greatness likewise there must be
feelings of greatness not from Merit but
from grace and having passed through
humiliation so in fact he's saying the
philosophers have not completely grasped
human nature what they're doing is a
little bit too abstract by comparison to
what Christianity is going to offer us
right a little bit earlier he said there
is no Doctrine more appropriate to the
human being than this which teaches us
our double capacity of receiving and
losing Grace because of the double Peril
to which we are exposed what is that
despair or Pride when we focus on our
greatness we are tempted to to pry when
we focus on our misery or littleness we
are tempted to despair neither of those
are what we actually want and he goes on
and he talks about something really
interesting here this is what we'll
conclude with
in 5 25 he says misery induces despair
Pride induces presumption
what can get us out of this the
Incarnation he says shows the human
being the greatness of their Misery by
the greatness of the remedy which they
required
so the Incarnation this Christian
doctrine which one can think about you
know and mull over and sort of meditate
out and and find to be also a mystery is
the leading clue out of this mistaken
bifurcation and oscillation between
sides he goes on to say the knowledge of
God without that of man's misery causes
Pride right so even knowing about God
even like having been you know preached
to and become a convert or something
like that if you don't understand the
human misery you're going to be prideful
the knowledge of human misery without
that of God causes despair why because
you look at things and you're like oh
this is crap I'm never going to get out
of this you know Only a God could save
us and then a God does come and save us
according to this narrative right and he
goes on and says the knowledge of Jesus
Christ so the Incarnation there again
constitutes the middle course
because in him we find both God and our
misery so this allows us to have a
proper perspective the right framework
for ourselves and you know this
shows us according to Pascal how to
continually make sense of our greatness
and our misery both at the very heart of
what it is to be a human being or we
could say at the core of the Human
Condition